so hello everybody i am here with jf
martel
jeff martel is a thinker he is a
filmmaker
uh just a cultural theorist he's written
a book called reclaiming art in the age
of artifice and also hosts a podcast
called weird studies
the strange thing about jf is that
several years ago someone pointed me to
him and said that we were like
doppelgangers that we
really look like each other even my wife
when she saw a picture of him thought
wow this guy really looks like you and
what's interesting is that a lot of his
ideas start from similar positions as
mine
he talks about the world as story about
how you know
reality is is built out of story and he
comes to conclusions that are slightly
different from me
so i think this is going to be a very
interesting discussion
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
yeah i'm looking forward to it and my
wife said the same thing
that's hilarious yeah yeah like brothers
more like yeah exactly like and we're
also both french canadian which is just
strange so we should come doing this in
french yeah
it's a little awkward but that we'll get
the hang of it we're both used to it
the thing is that um yeah i guess it
goes to show that we come
we come from a society that was until
very recently very homogeneous that we
could look so similar and not have the
same name
last name exactly you probably have some
bloodlines crossing
at some point in the past oh for sure
yeah in fact i think you're only like a
few hundred
you're you're in the eastern townships
yeah is that where you were yeah well i
grew up in eastern township so yeah oh
so i'm in ottawa so we're pretty close
anyways yeah
so so you wrote a book called reclaiming
art in the age of artifice and i've
heard you talk on several podcasts about
a certain approach to reality about
reality being made of stories so maybe
you can lay out
you know the basics of your idea and
then we can start to explore
the kind of the similarities and
differences with the things i'm talking
about
sure sure um so reclaiming out of
the age of artifice is a book i wrote a
few years ago now
um and the goal of the book
was to i had been working
in the media industry for some time at
that point and i'd become frustrated
with the types of
uh questions that um
my my fellow artists and i were getting
from
the people who were basically the
gatekeepers of the industry the types of
things that we were asked to
do this is not new every artist knows
this is working in
a big industries that you start off with
this vision this idea of what you'd like
to do and then of course
it's almost like you're holding a a
candle and the industry is a maze and
you your the goal is to somehow make it
across to the other end
with these howling winds through the
tunnels with the candles still
lit at the other end so i thought well
that's and this is i think is a
something that a lot of
artists have felt so i was just thinking
about that and instead of going the
usual route which is to say well
that's just the egocentric artist
wanting to
control you know that not answering to
the demands of culture but trying to get
their own
personal opinion across or their own
personal vision
but really the market knows what kind of
art should be made and one should just
kind of bow to that instead of going
that route i decided to go the other
route and i
drew on the artists that i love um
people like oscar wilde
uh people like uh albert
um flannery o'connor
you know i remember the the artist that
that i was into at the time stanley
kubrick you know and and just
going to see what what did they say
about the process
and i found that often what they said
resonated with what
my artist friends and i were feeling um
and uh they had just been the people
who'd been able to make it across the
maze with the candle
still lit and um and so then i thought
well what is it that we're doing
as artists so i became interested in the
question of art
and to be honest this is a question
that's preoccupied me for a long time
since i was a teenager i think that it's
one probably one of the
archetypal dialogues you'll hear in a
high school or sujet right it's the
what is our conversation oh that's art
that's not
that sort of thing well i decided to
take that question seriously
as a thought exercise at first as a
thought experiment
and then finally ended up because i was
writing for a magazine at the time
called reality sandwich i ended up
getting an opportunity to write a book
about that
and so i did and uh and uh
and so the book basically argues that um
art is a a means by which
the human being is able to capture
touch uh express the real
with a capital r so what is real what is
really real
um and that uh
art is innately um
spiritual and that uh
we have simply uh forgotten that and
there's there's something basically
fundamentally subversive about our
about art in the sense that it shows us
things outside of the usual frames of
reference that we
we we know them in so it will take for
example
you know the example i use in the book a
few on a few occasions is
you'll have someone take a vas with
sunflowers in it
and transform it into a weird menagerie
of alien monsters right to transform
them into something where
the sunflower which seems so known so
familiar to us suddenly becomes strange
again restored to its original
strangeness
because the theory is that we tend to
project our concepts on things
and then we reduce those things to those
concepts and art is a way of getting
through that
interface that kind of uh overlay of
conceptual
apprehension to get back to something
like
the original reality of creation
right um and i'm not saying that there's
a kind of gnosis in art
but i'm saying that at least it shows us
our unknowing so it's like an antinosis
it it removes the the idea that we can
uh know things with certainty it
restores us to what in the book i call
radical mystery that's what art does and
that's how you can
kind of distinguish something like uh
guernica
or the sistine chapel or an icon
from something like a car commercial or
that horrible milk commercial i'm sure
you remember in canada with where they
took beethoven's ninth and turned it
into
it was just the word milk being repeated
over and over again uh when we were kids
so like
that's sort of that type of
propagandistic uh
type of art that tells you how to feel
and think which i in the book i call
artifice
so it was an exercise in um
rehabilitating and weaponizing
an adolescent an adolescent feeling yes
and so one of the things that i've heard
you say is
is really this return to the
phenomenological which is something that
i've been
uh helping trying to get people to get
back to
which is that the reality we have access
to the reality of these things that
present themselves to us
in terms of you know the hot cold inside
outside these categories of experience
they're actually
the first categories right they're the
categories the world is made out of
the other categories like the scientific
categories are real but they're
secondary let's say to these first kind
of uh impressions the
this world of phenomena that we deal
with
and so maybe because you talk about the
vase i remember listening to you talk
about the
the vase in in this interview and you
mentioned how
by framing it let's say by putting it
into an image and then having you
having it called to your attention so
asking people to
attend to it then you are you're
you're making forcing the person to ask
themselves
what what is this like why is the vase
there like in
i think you remember in in this podcast
i listened to you're talking about a
movie where
the person uh focuses on the vase for
too long like lingers on the vase with
the camera and so you're
forced to ask yourself like why and
therefore ask yourself
well what is a vase like what is that
what what
what categories are kind of coming to us
in terms of
base a vessel right exactly so it's like
something that holds something else it's
something that that is uh
and therefore it becomes an analogous to
other vessels right you can think of
a mother or you can think of uh of a
house of anything that oceans something
yeah so there are all these different
things that kind of flood in
these analogies that flood in uh which
can kind of help you understand
why a vase is important and also why it
has why we even have a category of vase
it basically the image um turns the vase
the
i say vas i had the same let's just say
vase just because
it's nicer it's french it's vows yeah it
turns out it's just i'll say
let's just suppose let's read let's
let's let's uh okay so
the vaz is uh transmuted in almost an
alchemical way into a symbol
so in the book i talk a lot about signs
and symbols
and that we usually live in a a for
a city of signs um a town
with neon signs everywhere telling us
what things are
whether we're in the forest or in the on
a mountain doesn't matter we
we live in sign city uh everything has
its attributed
meaning everything has a label attached
to it but then
sometimes in life for a moment usually
there's a kind of satori moment or a
moment of clarity where oh my god the
strangeness of things
comes back comes to you and that's
that's comes through what i in the book
in art it
occurs through framing you frame out
something which normally would just be
part of the decor of ordinary life
but once framed it starts to um emit
what
thomas aquinas called radiance claritas
and that radiance does two things
formally speaking just by the by virtue
of being framed it
calls you back to the original mystery
of all things
it reminds you that we don't really know
what anything is we're kind of living in
this
mystery secondly the sp the specificity
of the object in the frame in this case
the vas
calls you to interpret to ask about this
object
this thing that you're looking at that
you don't know anymore and that's what
occasions
the um the process
of symbolic thinking of thinking in
terms of analogy
and so you start to think about
associations and
and some some are some associations have
become classic for example the vessel
the mother the ocean right the night
you know the things that contain the
things that um and those associations
have become quite
standard but but my my gambit
is that modern art and it's at its best
uh allows for new associations
uh and and so so that that there's never
uh there's never a symbol dictionary
that's complete
right yeah that this is always in the
process of being
discovered and and uh okay so yeah
yeah so this is this is really for me
it's very fascinating to hear you speak
because
what i hear when i listen to is i hear
kind of two things going on
and and for me at least the way that
i've tried to present it has really been
two things
and so this notion of the mystery or
this kind of entering into
the mystery if you think of an ancient
temple or you know a church
you have the space of mystery which is
the altar let's say
and that's where the the magical event
happened the the event
that binds us together as a community
the event that
connects us to something higher and and
so it is beyond description although you
can describe it you know that it's also
containing something which is leading
beyond it right so
higher up okay that sense yeah and so
usually those
the analogies that go with that are kind
of this moment of clarity that you talk
about
or the moment of light this idea of a
beam of light or
a vision or uh so there are all these
unveiling you know all these types of
imagery right and then there's another
space right which is the space of the
margin
and that's usually where the strange
happens
and so that's where like for example in
medieval manuscripts you had
uh monsters right you would have the the
marginalia where you have all these
mixed creatures you have
surprising you have inversions you have
uh
you know rabbits fighting men and
and all this strange stuff that happened
in the margins and you see it also in
the
in the shape of the church you have the
same you have the gargoyles on the
on the outside of the church and so the
gargoyles are this the surprising hybrid
uh strange right the weird the this is
that's where the weird kind of occurs um
and so so to me there's like there's an
interesting thing because you you kind
of join those together and i know that
there's a way in which that's not
completely
off because the guardian like the
monster guardian like a cerberus or
some other creature is usually
represented
it's like if you're going into the holy
place right so if you're going into the
mystery
you'll encounter a monster because he's
protecting the holy place and so
you see the cherub on the veil of the
temple you know the sphinx the
the these these these uh these kind of
bull wink bold creature that you see in
mesopotamian temples
they're guarding they're guarding the
mystery um
but then when you go beyond when you you
have to kind of
pass them they're like a veil and then
beyond that there's
the illumination you would say and then
you yes and you
then you can grasp let's say the vas
in it's in a way that is beyond all its
particulars
so it's like you graph you get this
thing it's like you this this
and you said gnosis i'm totally fine
with that term like you get this insight
which will
then be it's beyond words and it's
beyond the particular and you get it
uh but what's fascinating to me is that
for it seems like for you those two
things are kind of the same
yeah yeah strange that's really yeah go
for it
no that's really interesting that you
bring that up actually um
there's a uh protestant theologian
rudolph otto
i don't know if you're familiar with his
work but he uh he came up with a concept
in his work which he calls mysterio the
uh
because in latin mysterium fascinates
tremendous
the fascinating and terrible mystery
and he's he hit this is um
this isn't a work that explores uh that
tries to capture
the nature of the sacred and what otto
argues is that the sacred is always
a two-prong thing the sacred reveals
itself as
fascinating in the in a in the positive
sense not in the sense of casting a
magic spell but in the sense the sense
of that aquinas means by illuminating it
draws you in
it it it is um it is a
type of gnosis it it confirms something
that you
could only dream and hope was true
and shows it to you in a way that's
beyond words
at the same time strangely mysteriously
it is also
terrible because the sacrifice it asks
of you
is uh is is terrible
it's like abram and isaac isaac material
right
um and so it's both and um
i tend to be um
this is super interesting that you
brought you kind of put your finger
right on it there i think between when
it comes to
the two of us and the way we approach
these things i think you're right i tend
to be more manichaean
or i'll which means more dualistic
about this thing um because
i am uncertain as to whether
the real capital r the ultimate is
something that would be
that is um is something that
would bring one joy or
absolute horror i don't know i don't
know that
i believe that it's good that's why i'm
a practicing catholic
but i don't know it i don't feel it i
feel like there's a chance
that the illumination if if it were
complete
would be like what the germans
experienced at the end of raiders of the
lost ark
right yeah well for sure there's that
threat in scripture and that threat
in right in uh in the idea of the of god
or or
the this idea of the the revelation uh
of vishnu right in in where he removes
his mask and then you know this thing
that
that that he see by nagarjuna is like
this i think that's his name
he's like this this insane thing uh and
you get the sense of that in scripture
as well where god you know when someone
asks to see god's face god says you
can't
if you see my face it's going to destroy
you
uh right and it seems like at least in
christianity that
all of that gets resolved or resolved
it's not it's resolved in the sense that
it's brought together in the cross
which is that moment where
death and glory are joined together in
that moment where the horror and the
highest thing are kind of joined
together in one image
um and so i think i agree with you in
that sense
that that there is something and there's
also this idea of the
the relationship between the divine
darkness and the divine light and you
see that i talk about that
quite a bit because i carve icons and so
i actually make opaque images people
always talk about icons as windows
to heaven and i'm like well i make
carvings and so it's more it
has more to do with this in in the old
testament there's a there are
certain places where when god's glory
comes it's like a darkness
it's like this darkness which comes in
and sometimes it's both like in the
transfiguration of christ it says
they were they were overshadowed by
light
so it's like a cloud of light and so
it's both
a dark and light it's like something
which shadows you which
stops you from seeing the light but also
you see the light so it's like this i i
see what you're talking about in terms
of the duality of the
of the revelation let's say right right
well i'm glad
yeah i'm just um and you you say that
christianity resolves it
i think that you're right i think that
christianity resolves it
uh but i guess i'm just not
quite sure that that uh uh
christianity's right christianity is
right in the in what sense do you mean
i just i i'm just much more ambiguous
with well
like i said again i'll say i'm i am a
christian
but i'm a christian i need dostoyevsky
said that uh
he says my hosannas were forged in the
immense furnace of doubt
so i guess i'm still in the immense
furnace of doubt
yeah and uh and so i but what i
what i love about and also i wouldn't
want it any other way
in the sense that i think that um
it is important that we
that the exp the spirit of exploration
that characterizes the human
um is given is vindicated and allowed to
go the whole way
some of my favorite christian writers
most of them became christians after
they
at the end of their careers are the
decadent writers of the late 19th
century people like
jk reesmann uh yeah right
uh and uh and also like aubry beardsley
and
people who realized at the height
really of that moment where the modern
kicks into full gear right the end of
the 19th century
these guys realize that in order to
affirm
meaning again we would have to affirm
the most awful meaning we would have to
affirm
sin and darkness and evil in order for
the axis of good and evil to even exist
we have to go down there
and i think that they i don't know how
conscious of it they were
but when you look at the work you look
at griezmann's series of novels
from arab to the late works where he was
basically a
i think not an advocate but uh yeah oh
yeah like a lay monk
um yeah he uh there's a there's a
movement there that's very important and
i think that the way for a modern to
re-enter
uh to rediscover what there is to
discover
in those old religious traditions i
think that that path
the left-hand path as they call it in
magic is is a
super risky but um some
sometimes maybe necessary one and so i
i'm kind of
that's why i'm i i'll emphasize
the unseeable face of god and point out
that that face
is unseeable because it's monstrous and
i i emphasize that side that doesn't
mean i disagree with you at
least i agree with you 100 yeah
well we it's like i always try to remind
people that we do eat the blood
and body of christ right that's the
highest sacrament it's like
it is you can say that it doesn't refer
to cannibalism at all but that would be
actually missing
the point of how christ unites the
extremes
in his person and in and in his
sacraments ultimately
right but the thing that i'm worried
about mostly is that there is this image
of especially in exploring the darker
aspects like there is this image of of
losing yourself
you know because that's the imagery of
the demonic or these
these hybrid creatures that appear you
see in these images of hell of like
early renaissance or late medieval
images of hell
these kind of monstrous hybrids and all
of this exploration
um
interestingly enough before they were
actually almost more positive these
monsters because they were just in the
margins of the doc
of the document like they were not just
not in hell
in the sense of the the this
ins just in terms of negative they were
just ontologically on the edge
and so they just created a border for
for the
peripheral yeah this peripheral kind of
of of weirdness that appeared on the
edge
uh and so it's the
highest version of that i think is i
don't know if you've seen heard me talk
about saint christopher which
is something that i've been trying to
talk about quite a bit so saint
christopher
is a a giant in some traditions but he's
also a dog-headed man in other
traditions
and so he is this kind of monstrous
dog-headed creature
who uh in in the legend he works
he's looking for the strongest king and
he ends up like actually working for
satan
and then finally he's looking to work
for the strongest king but he ends up
submitting to the baby
by crossing this child across the river
uh
and then and and there are versions of
it where he's a giant other that he's a
like a giant dog-headed monster so the
idea is that the monstrous or the
the the hybrid its best possibility
is a bridge because it's on the edge and
so it can actually carry the logos or
the light or the divine revelation
further out into the world but it also
guards you it also is like a it's like a
a guard against improper
improper uh say defamation or like you
know desacralization something like that
right well it's kind of like reminds me
what mcluhan was saying about artists
that that marshall mcluhan the canadian
media theorist right
whom you've discussed on your show and i
really enjoyed the interview you did
with what was the name of the scholar
yeah right yeah christian would be
someone you would really like to talk to
by the way because he's
he's uh he's very interested in in
similar subjects
same subject as you yeah fantastic um
the the mcluhan described the artist as
a probe
um or as an was it um
uh i can't remember the term you use
like something long distance early
warning system or something like that
that's what he described art
right um and uh and so
the but the probe um
it goes out into the chaos into the
margins into the areas that we don't
know
and incurs a risk by doing that um
there is a risk i i ultimately think
that if you're going to turn a sign
and again for your listeners who aren't
familiar like a sign is just basically
the way we conceptualize a particular
object in the world like
this lamp i'm looking at here or the
screen it's all very clear to me there's
i see it and i see the label si screen
right i don't need to think about it i
can just
go about my day and use it but in order
for to take a sign
let's say let's go back to the vas of
sunflowers and transform it into a
symbol
the process by which that happens i've
discovered all right
is that the sign needs to move through a
zone of indeterminacy
the sign can't go from sign to symbol
like a light switch
it has to first become monstrous uh it
has to go
into a place where you don't recognize
it anymore and
i think any artist will recognize that
moment where they look at their work and
they don't know what they're looking at
anymore like none of it makes sense like
everything looks
off and that's the in a way that's kind
of a sign that you're moving
towards the something new right there
needs to be a place where you don't
a moment where you don't know anymore
what you're looking at yeah
and and i think that that process of of
sending
things that are familiar into the depths
where they become unfamiliar is
dangerous
and i don't think it's a coincidence
that mental illness is
is prevalent it's related to artists
related to artists
uh because there's that risk um and so
kind of you have to become a kind of
dog-headed monster a little bit
um and and that's that's that's okay
but there is a risk and the risk is real
and i don't want to try to say like that
the risk
is uh yeah i don't i wouldn't
want to try to imply that the risk isn't
real because it is
like a way to say it that might surprise
you is the idea of baptizing something
because that's what baptism is right
you don't see the symbolism as much in
catholic baptism but
let's say in orthodox baptism baptism is
a descent into the waters right you
right you go down into the waters and
there are these you know these little
river gods that are there
uh you see in the icon of christ you see
these little kind of ancient
roman river gods that are kind of down
there and so when you and there's
prayers like at the beginning of baptism
where you chase out the
dragons from the waters before the
person goes down and so the idea is that
when you go down when you bring
something down to reform it like you
said
there's a danger in that in that moment
that moment of unformedness
uh we usually tend to focus just on the
coming out and this kind of
this re coming back into light and then
having this insight or having
this higher insight about the thing but
we you're right even myself i don't tend
to talk about
the the unformed part you know if i
carbon nikon
you know then that piece of of stone is
is quite pristine
right before i start and in between the
piece of stone and the final thing
there's a lot of messiness that happens
in that proc
in that moment right right and and and
there are the process asks of you
uh something that i've been talking with
an australian artist named
andrew antonio he's a very talented
surreal
surrealist kind of painter
and he uh yeah he was talking to me
yesterday about the the confrontations
the the paths you find that you know
that if you follow that path too far
it might lead to something that you're
not ready for
right there's a whole interior world and
i think there's something else that art
tells us whether it's
uh liturgical art or wonderful secular
right i don't i actually don't think
there's a difference i think art i think
i don't i don't think there's any such
thing as profane art
my personal theory is that art is
inherently sacred
if it's real art you know um but then
you have to get into the
the unpleasant game of defining that but
whatever
um but he was uh where was i going i
totally lost my treasure
your australian friend who talked about
the danger of going into certain right
the danger right that there are um that
there's a that artist calls us to um
develop
and explore our our interiority
which is probably the biggest problem we
have today is that
we there's a full-on assault going on on
interiority
in our culture uh we are being called to
think of ourselves as
um purely external creatures
like completely oriented to what's
outside um there's very little in our
culture especially now with the advent
of
of ubiquitous digital culture there's
very little opportunity for people to
go in uh and art requires you
if you're going to do it properly to go
in and
going in is there's a reason we don't
want to do it
it's not pleasant uh it can lead to all
kinds of um
strange and unpleasant discoveries and
but the but the the theory is or the
gamble is that it's
worse not to do it than to do it as bad
as it is to go inside
uh it would be worse not to
because yeah and of course all your
horrors will manifest externally yeah
well it's inte it's it's fascinating
because i i
i've i kind of i found my own kind of
solution to that which you probably
probably won't agree with me but for me
the the
the the solution that i came to in terms
of art
first of all in terms of the problem of
art and artifice is right
my the discovery of more traditional art
or liturgical art for example
actually breaks down that barrier right
in terms of the difference between
let's say an object of consumption the
way that we think of it you know like a
how now we have objects of consumption
and then we also have
uh our things that are there to give you
a message
then we also have the high art let's say
that is supposed to be more
exploratory in liturgical art that kind
of joins together because the object you
make is gonna be used
it doesn't just it's not just looked at
right it's not just like uh it's like
not just like an object of contemplation
but
it's going to be used in the prayer it's
going to be used in the liturgy
and so it it kind of binds
the different aspects of of art together
in
objects yes i i think that's fine
i think that's that's an important point
and i think that's good
uh i just think that we've lost our way
of discussing
that part of the liturgical art that
isn't artifice
yeah the claritas part the the art part
is what we've lost the words or sin
signs to
to determine but that's what i'm trying
to recover
i perfectly agree with you that a work
of art can be also a work of artifice in
the sense that it can have an
instructive or functional
role to play in a particular context
nevertheless
there's a difference between a good icon
and a bad icon oh yeah for sure
and how do we talk about that right yeah
i mean most people look at orthodox
icons and they just see the same thing
right but as i'm sure that as an icon
i'm certain that as a nikon artist
yourself as someone who is a carver in
the orthodox tradition you're very much
aware of the subtle differences that
makes
i don't know like an andre rublev
different from
someone else's icon um
it's definitely no there's definitely
there's definitely something
that makes that makes uh there's
definitely a a
difference between a very bad icon and a
good icon
the the strangeness is that it seems
that seems that in terms of uh
like let's say in terms of miracles it
doesn't matter
and so no like so some of the really
worst icons become
like these centers of pilgrimage people
like
have these and then it's like it becomes
the center of a whole community and you
think wow that's wonderful
and then but you're something in your
mind telling yourself still a bad icon
yeah exactly even if like i recognize
this is amazing and all these people
loving each other and kind of
surrounding this thing it's great but
still it's a it's a bad icon yeah that's
a great point though
because it goes to show that yeah yeah
that's
nonetheless and their way like the
reason why we recognize certain artists
as being
like rubella for example is a great
example uh
he was the joining he kind of joined
everything together because he was
really recognized as a holy person
early on and he actually is canonized
now he's a he's a saint like you can get
an icon of ruble
of him like not just his icon but of of
his portrait
uh but he also was recognized as someone
to copy
and so but his work is very different
from what came before so he's actually
there's quite a lot of innovation in his
work
but he was rapidly recognized as
something that was setting a new
path that that those that aren't so good
need to follow it's like
right here is something that's really
kind of showing itself brightly
and then telling all these other artists
that are mediocre to say okay just look
at rublev like
follow ruby these are like church
councils saying that like church
moscow council saying look at rublev
copy ruble because
a lot of you guys are just off the off
the rails in terms of icons
well that gives the lie to the popular
idea that icon art has never changed
uh because it does innovate in ways but
it innovates through
uh i guess you call it through a kind of
grace uh it's not
it's not it's not about individual
self-expression
it's not like rubella is like i'm going
to do things my way
it's more like he had he he encountered
a problem
uh and he found he he
he received a solution right yeah and
that's how art
evolves and i i think that's more common
in secular art than we think
is what might think because and i
totally think
i think i completely understand why you
found because i know you started in
contemporary art and then you've
discovered traditional art um and went
into that world and
i i can see uh why one would do that
because there the these ideas that we're
talking about aren't that foreign there
there's that's kind of like yeah art
doesn't come from individual human
beings it comes from
beyond um in the secular culture we have
no language to discuss this nevertheless
we have things like guernica you know
picasso's guernica or
um uh moby dick
you know or hamlet i don't know like or
an emily dickinson
poem it's like eight lines these things
they they too reveal things to us and so
we have to be able to
to to figure out what it is that's going
on in secular art that it's
so unsecular yeah um it just can't be
secular
it has to call us back to the mystery
yeah and to the sacred
and i think you're right and there are
artists that are doing that now
i think one of the difficulties of the
modern time is
first of all it was this race towards
genius and just race towards the
personal
and so you know this idea of especially
you see you see it in abstract
expression as
especially in the most where they they
have all these artists that have this
like one characteristic style
and then you recognize their paintings
and then they it's like it's as if their
whole person gets embodied in this style
and and then it becomes a marketing ploy
it
becomes an easy way to market them as
well and sell their paintings for
millions of dollars but you see that
already
in the early 20th century with a lot of
the the early modernists
um but there are some things that
i think even in liturgical art that they
discovered or that they
brought forth it can be recuperated and
so i know some
um i know some icon painters that are
using rothko
in terms of you know rothko's ideas of
push and pull
and and this notion of how space and
color interact with each other
and so but now more subtly to the
service of something
which they think is more communal and is
more
kind of bringing people together um and
i think the same thing happens with
cubism and with the early
early kind of formal developments that
happen in modernism
my take on it was that especially
arriving in the
in the like early 2000s or like late 90s
i felt like there was just nothing else
happening
yeah that they like people were
regurgitating
merced in one way or another and the
painters were all regurgitating
the early modernists in one way or the
other and so i thought so
how did this happen like what happened
because there was this
race at the beginning of the 20th
century towards this radical innovation
and this
this surprise of the new uh and then it
actually it seems like it actually kind
of petered out
even before world war ii and then after
world war ii then
it's just like because any everything
warhol did was already in data
like that's fine no i agree you know
yeah yeah i don't know how do you
especially inter because you're not
necessarily visual artists but like in
terms of visual art to me
it seemed like even in terms of visual
innovation
they they it's like it was like this
quick burning uh
you know thing that they lit and it went
then it was over and now people were
being traditionalists about breaking
tradition it was
it was like this strange this strange
way of thinking
i think that uh i mean in fact that's a
that's a huge question that we could
discuss
for hours but i think that one quick
answer that i'd like to give
like the venture uh a theory i guess is
that
um i tend to think that changes in art
happen in poetry first so
um and or at least that's where they
become more noticeable
in this case i would think that if you
look at paris in the mid
19th century and london a little later
in germany of course you'll find the
i'll go back to the whole idea of
decadence right
um of these decadent literature decadent
poetry what is the archetypal figure of
decadent poetry
it is the anemic uh
last in line aristocrat the last of his
house
who is so bored with life
with modernity that all that's left for
him is sensual pleasure
and so like risman's character is the
ultimate
he locks himself up in a palace of
strange curiosities bizarre grotesque
plants and
like turtles and laid with gold and all
kinds of queer
and he just luxuriates in this pleasure
of the senses until
finally he can just die because there's
nothing left
of the world there's nothing left except
surfaces
um acedia right this is the way the
monks
the monks who suffered from this
condition in the middle ages were
these they were told that they suffer
from something called activists
the disease of our age pretty much yes
and then what you see in afterwards
and this you know what you see is like
data
is the kind of codification of that
decadent feeling affect that was new
when when baudelaire and bisman and
poe were talking about it all of a
sudden it's codified
it's instrumentalized and it happens to
serve uh a commodity culture very
well um a culture that's completely
uh in fact you know the whole data dream
of a world
of obliterating the line between art and
life we've accomplished that
we live in the utopia of the dadas and
the situationists
in a way uh we live in a world where
there's no more
boundary between art and life um
between uh yes so so
so i think that that assyria which the
those those decadent poets
poets explored first then just became a
generalized social phenomenon
and you and you see it play out in all
these crazy
uh theatrical uh weird theatrical uh
events like uh like the nazi rallies or
like that ridiculous [ __ ] we saw in
washington a few weeks ago
this type of like pretending to care
about pretending to be part of
history like fabricating events trying
to get us to feel something again
um i think that we're just apathetic as
a culture and we need to
wake up um and uh and that's
that's my my take on that your final
word is that we need to wake up i agree
i totally agree
uh yeah i tend to see
and that maybe brings me too also to the
one of the aspects that i've been trying
to develop which is art as participation
yeah you know one of the things that
i've been trying to point people towards
is the difference between the modern
notion of art as a kind of aesthetic
experience or an exterior aesthetic
experience you know
going to the opera going to the concert
who's looking at a movie watching a
movie
all of this is different from the
participative
art that ancient cultures had or you
know that
the idea of a dance or you know or
singing folk songs together
or sitting around a fire and
participating
and celebrating our stories right you
know
even the iliad was sung right people
didn't read it
they would have bars that would come and
would sing it to them because it was
their story and they would kind of have
this participation
and i think that like you said one of
the difficulties of something like that
the fascist tendency is
in noticing the vacuousness of
let's say pleasure this kind of exterior
pleasure this surface pleasure and
the entertainment culture that we embody
is this desire to participate and
they're looking for places
to enter into the story yes and the
political sphere is an easy and scary
place
to enter into the story where you take a
side you have a bad guy
you have an enemy you know you you you
can even make them really really evil
like in terms of the queue type people
and then you know where you are and who
you're fighting and what you're doing
and so it makes you feel
alive in a way that uh that i can
i can sympathize with but also is
extremely dangerous because it's very
limited
it's limited and it's it's fundamentally
it gets it gets everything
exactly half right and exactly half
wrong exactly right
so so being half right is not a good
thing in life
it's like the worst it's worth it's
better to be wrong
than being half right um so is there
corruption at the top
on both sides of the aisle politically
of course there is
um uh and and so but
there's that's where subtlety becomes
very
important you know and looking at
yourself becomes very important and not
also the holier-than-thou
feeling that the the fascist sentiment
encourages that we are the pure
and they are the impure and all of a
sudden all of the stuff that we can't
acknowledge about ourselves it gets
projected onto the other
not a good thing not a good path yeah
that's why like for example when i talk
about the church building let's say and
i try to get people to kind of
experience it because it's not i talk
about it but it's also experiencing it
is that the church building let's say
the way it's built like
when you enter into it it has three
parts it has the altar
it has the nave and it has the narthex
that's the those are the main parts
and the narthex is that place of
relationship with the outside where the
monsters
appear you know the gargoyles and all of
his stuff and so there's a hierarchy of
being
but it's not a it's not a simple in out
identity right it's not as simple us
them
because it's it's actually a hierarchy
which moves out into the outside and
into the
indifferentiated possibilities which lay
outside of my identity
and so it's a healthier way to encounter
identity and some people
will will um will object because there
is
to a certain extent a recognition of the
monstrosity of the strange like
and when i encounter something that i
don't recognize like a stranger
there is something monstrous of that but
if i know that
that monstrosity is also
is also part of how it like i recognize
it right it's structural
it's just structural it's there and so i
see the stranger and i recognize oh
that's weird
and then it's like okay well now move on
like it's it's i don't know i can get
over it
it's like i don't have to necessarily
like throw a lance at it right
right it's just part of like it's just
part of how the world lays itself out
and
the idea of having like a saint like
saint christopher or a certain other you
know say moses the the ethiopian
certain is this with the horns to uh the
old testament moses
yeah moses who came down with horns
there yeah exactly that's a fascinating
story
but so to me it's more like trying to
get people to go back
into a proper story like not
not the weird nationalistic story but a
story which has this
this space for the strange but it also
looks towards
the altar right that it's not completely
fascinated with the snake either because
like i need to my my opinion that can be
very dangerous because it
because those monsters can also eat you
like they really yeah
absolutely absolutely that's the great
hope is that that
uh you're right about all this
it's like my opinion it's our great hope
uh like i agree with you and i think
that speaking
to the the importance of participation
which i think is really important i
think i saw you talk about this in a
talk
sometime uh how traditional art is
participatory so it invites
i think that's that's key um i think
that good uh
secular i don't like you that were
secular but let's say non-traditional
art or
um i even think that that's wrong i
think there's a tradition even in
secular art
anyways like yeah uh in all art there's
a participatory
call there's a call to participate um i
wouldn't want somebody to read me moby
dick because it would take a week
but i love to be able to sit down and
read it i don't think the technology of
the novel
although it's not an oral technology
still participates in
of that yeah there's something about
that so
and and something's going on in that
book of all books i think that
it's the closest i've read to uh kind of
pro
not profane but secular scripture in a
weird way
but there is there is even in terms of
like uh
the idea of the monstrous like the idea
that the monsters were in the ornaments
in medieval manuscripts like there was a
relationship between
ornamentation and the monstrous there's
also
something inevitable about the secular
uh like there's something about how
gouge used to say he was a decorator
and and and i actually think that's a
really interesting idea
like he said there's a role for
ornamentation and
and it's kind of i wouldn't call it vain
beauty but a kind of
a recognition of the sensual aspect of
reality
but it's also a decorative it's also
decorative
like it's it's something you do after at
the end of the day right it's like it's
it's like the the rest of the house you
need the house before you can decorate
it so the house has to stay
you need exactly you need the house
that's a good yeah they can't be built
on
sand right uh so but uh about the
participation thing that there's a
difference between
uh there are different types of
participation uh in sociology they have
a term
communitas right which uh um means uh
you know when you go into a place and
you feel like you're together with
everybody everybody's on the same page
on the same wavelength there's this
feeling of community that develops that
that suddenly
spontaneously appears it can go it can
be
there are different types and the type
of communities that i've experienced
in in religion um
in my own religious practice which is
catholic but it's obviously
uh available in orthodoxy but also in i
would argue in buddhism and hinduism
is that it gives you community it's a
community of aloneness
um as opposed to a dionysiak fury my nad
like
wild community of the of the of the pack
or the herd
um you know the the greeks talked about
the the mine ads which
the women who follow dionysus and who go
into we go into this
this nocturnal frenzy and like rampage
through the woods and
tear men to pieces if they found them or
animals like just
yeah right so so that's communitas too
that's a type of community
um but uh and the greeks were willing to
recognize that that existed but of
course there was always the
how do we try to contain this bit of a
danger there yeah
so so so the uh the but the type of
communities i've felt in
religion is very different it's not so
much that i'm with everybody here we're
all one tribe
it's more like we're together to the
extent that
at this moment we realize that we're all
kind of alone
facing this thing and the call is being
made to each individual
and personally and i try to
argue in my book that art is similar to
that
that herman melville didn't write moby
dick
despite what he thought didn't write
moby dick for
a mass of people i think he sold like a
couple of thousand copies in his
lifetime and died very poor
he wrote it for one person and i think
that the
the proper way to approach a work of art
is to assume because
your guess is as good as anybody else
assume that that person was you
approach the book as though it was
written for you that's
it was with that attitude when i read
the bible
that i was finally able to understand
what my religion had been trying to tell
me all along
it's not about judging other people it's
about you
and you're alone and in the in the
moment of communities in a proper
i would argue in a proper art context
communitas brings us back to our
aloneness and it's our aloneness that we
share
not this kind of tribal nationalistic
uh togetherness that that absolves us of
responsibilities individuals yeah
well i would say that the christian
idea of love it does in fact try to
balance out
the the the two extremes like the
the idea of a solipsism or this kind of
just
single uh radical loneliness and
the the fusion this tribal fusion that
you talk about you know in the
yeah i think i'm sorry yeah
the trinity so in the trinity that seems
to be what is expressed at the highest
level
it's like a radical radical union with
radical
separation right so it's like there's no
confusion between the persons
but they are completely one and that
seems to be what we're called to do as
christians and
the way that it re sac reveals itself to
us or the way that
supposed to be lived is actually through
self-sacrifice like
the way that i'm not alone is the way
that i love others
so it's no it's not so much that what i
get from others that
makes me not alone it's what i give and
and how i'm willing to
to kind of open and give myself to to
those around me
that is what connects me to them and so
it's a it's a weird it's like an
inversion of the passionate party like
of the
you know of this of the rave where
everybody is all fused in the beat
but they're all there to kind of get as
much
pleasure as they can in that moment you
know right
right no that's that's a very good point
and i i fully agree with
that yeah yeah um look i think we've
been going for quite a while this has
been
a very interesting discussion i'm happy
that i finally
talked to my to my doppelganger and uh
and i it's funny because i didn't know
that you were a catholic like i didn't
even know that you were uh
that you were a practicing catholic i
just saw i just saw your your
talk about weird stuff and i and i guess
it makes sense then you would be on the
makers in mystic podcast because i guess
it's mostly a kind of a like a christian
podcast but um
yes but i mean weird studies is uh i i
co-host weird studies with phil ford
who is a musicologist at indiana
university bloomington and he
is uh he's a buddhist so um we
uh we like to explore the the
in-betweens of things right the
strangeness of things the strangeness of
things that's what
that's what gets me off it's weirdness
what can i say
so so uh tell people where they can find
your stuff like do you have a website do
you have a
yeah i have a website that i haven't
updated in forever called reclaiming art
the address is reclaiming our dark.com
reclaimingart.com
and uh weird studies weirdstudies.com
it's probably the best way to find me
these days
um uh that's our our podcast that i
co-host with phil ford and
and aside from that yeah if you just
yeah i've written a few things
you could probably track down some
articles and essays if you're interested
and of course my book reclaiming art in
the age of artifice is available at all
virtual bookstores virtual bookstore
it's literally available in no single
physical books
exactly unless you pick them up outside
and we're going to and we're both
actually going to be part of the mystic
makers and mystics event that they're
doing in march so people could stay
tuned to that they'll probably be some
some social media posting about it and
jeff and i will both be speaking
at that event and with questions appear
question periods and stuff it's too bad
that we're not in the same place it
would have been nice to meet you in
person and
right to shake your hand well we're
almost neighbors so
once this all ends this ridiculousness
then we'll be able to meet
that would be great that would be great
so thanks for your time i appreciate it
thank you so much hope you enjoyed my
discussion with jf martel
you might have noticed the most recent
opening of my youtube channels which was
made by jack wilmet
jack wilmet runs a youtube very
successful youtube channel called the
disrupt
youtube channel where he does some
gaming and some vr stuff and so he
he made this for me which i find it very
interesting and so i'd like to hear your
comments about
it below in the comment section and as
you know everything we do in the
symbolic world
is due to your support so go check out
the symbolicworld.com
support if you want to help out this
project we've got a lot of things
on the line in the future including more
french content
translation of the website more
involvement as well
in terms of all the other stuff that
that has been around the symbolic world
so thanks again and i will talk to you
very soon